[Music]
most people to echo the words of henry
david thoreau are leading lives of quiet
desperation and go to the grave with the
song still in them and I find that
tragic and so if there's anything that
my work is about it's about helping
people become cognizant of that and to
take action so that they don't become
that person leading a life of quiet
desperation which I think a lot of
people are and and I found that
heartbreaking you know what's your major
malfunction right now what's the thing
that keeps you up at night who do you
resent the most what are you afraid of
what do you want to achieve
what's an what's an what do you think is
in your way I'm not here to tell you
what to do or how to live your life but
I believe in your greatest expression
and I'm gonna hold space for you I was a
daily drinker I was drinking vodka
tonics in the shower in the morning and
hiding drinks throughout the day and you
know ending up in blackouts and and I
burned every Bridge that I had I was
virtually unemployable at the end I was
sleeping on a bare mattress and a crappy
apartment with no furniture in it my
options were had been eliminated my life
was eviscerated my family didn't want
anything to do with me I'd lost my
friendships I had no way forward and I
just continued to dig that hole deeper
and deeper and deeper when I was 39
years old on the cusp of turning 40 I
was 50 pounds overweight I had been an
athlete in college but that was very
much in my rearview mirror
to junk food addicts it's not taking
care of myself
physically mentally or emotionally and I
had a health scare shortly before my
40th birthday I decided to change
didn't happen over on the one hand I
love pain I love trying to push the
outer edges of the envelope of what the
pain experience is in a physical sense
and it's also been my greatest teacher
in terms of things that I've
accomplished but also my errant ways as
well pain is truly the only thing that's
ever gotten me to change so it's been my
growth accelerator as well as my
reminder of when I've gone astray I mean
I was a very awkward insecure kid who
had a lot of difficulty making friends
and and figuring out what the rules for
her life were and I was also somebody
who is not athletically inclined at all
I was the kid with the eye patch and the
headgear picked last for kickball and
all of that
but the one thing that I was actually
fairly okay at was swimming and when
you're good at something when you're a
kid and you're having difficulty in
other areas that's what you're going to
gravitate towards and and that's what I
did and I learned quickly that I was not
the most talented swimmer but in my
early teens I realized that if I was
willing to put in the work and do
certain things that other people weren't
willing to do that I could bridge that
talent gap and pick up a lot of white
space and that meant getting comfortable
with pain to bring it back to your
question so throughout my teens I would
I would routinely throw down crazy sets
in the pool that no one was willing to
do and I was doing it because I knew I
wasn't the most talented and if I wanted
to compete at the highest level that's
what would be required
how did you go in school you're being
bullied at one point you see this
opportunity to get better
what do you start telling yourself or
doing to be able to make Payne your
friend to push past it so that you could
begin to you know beat other people at
something it's almost like a deep
meditative state and it's a very one
you know one-to-one relationship between
the pain that you're willing to suffer
and the progress that you're going to
make and I saw swimming as my way
forward in my way out and so what that
meant was the more that I was willing to
suffer and the more likely it would be
that I was going to create a positive
trajectory out of this painful scenario
that I found myself in I would have a
vision board where I'd literally write
those times out in very large block
letters with a magic marker and put them
above my bed or on my mirror in my
bathroom and constantly reminding myself
and reinforcing myself about why I was
doing what I was doing so I don't know
that I would have called it a vision
board at that time it was more of a
practice of engaging in in in aspiration
like I had pictures of all my heroes and
all of that and I think intuitively I
was looking towards a better life for
myself I was somebody who who by the
time I was 18 years old was an
individual had a lot of promise and
there was a lot of people very invested
in my future I was graduating I
graduated top of my class in high school
I got into all the colleges I applied to
all the Ivy League's I was a top-ranked
swimmer competing at the very highest
level world rank the whole deal and so
my future looked very bright and then
alcohol got introduced to my life and it
was a very progressive decline in my
aspirations and at the very end I was a
daily drinker I was drinking vodka
tonics in the shower in the morning and
hiding drinks throughout the day and
you know ending up in blackouts and more
than you know my fair share of
incomprehensible you know demoralizing
situations and I burned every Bridge
that I had I was virtually unemployable
at the end I was sleeping on a bare
mattress and a crappy apartment with no
furniture in it my options were I had
been eliminated my life was eviscerated
my family didn't want anything to do
with me
I've lost my friendships I had no way
forward and I just continued to dig that
hole deeper and deeper and deeper until
one day I had that moment that you hear
with people who are in recovery that
that moment of clarity where I realized
I just couldn't live this way any longer
my elevator had you know gone down to
the bottom floor and and the and and I
met my pain threshold you know back to
the this thesis around pain like I had
reached a point where I could no longer
tolerate the pain of my current
situation and the fear the pain
associated with the fear of change was
eclipsed by the pain that I was feeling
in that moment and that's what motivated
me to change I went to a treatment
center where I lived for a hundred days
which is pretty long time to be in a
rehab center and I did that because I
knew if I didn't get this right that my
life was done you know and so I took
that opportunity seriously I recognized
that despite the fact that I think I'm a
smart guy my best thinking had me
literally institutionalized and that if
I couldn't get a grasp on how to live
and develop some new skills and and a
new toolbox for how to approach my life
that that I was going to end up in jail
or I was gonna kill somebody else or
myself I think for me it's really
anchored in awareness and presence you
know on that staircase I was able to
really understand that I was having an
important moment in my life and the
reason I was able to recognize that was
because I had that moment so many years
prior when I decided to get sober it was
a very specific moment in time where I
made a decision and that decision set in
motion a series of events that changed
my life so completely that I couldn't
imagine my life had I not made that
decision and I was able to see and
understand and recognize that once again
I was being visited by just such an
opportunity it was something that I
could feel inside of me and and I think
it's because I'd learned to be present
to be aware of myself and my environment
and one thing I always talk about is the
fact that you know I'm not anything
special with this I think we're all
visited with moments like this in our
life that if we can develop that the
wherewithal to have the awareness around
the circumstances surrounding whatever
event it is that you can leverage that
crack you know in the door to make some
significant changes and I'm somebody who
and I've heard you talk about this
before I'm somebody who when I make a
decision like that's it
you know I can I can step over that line
or walk through that door and not look
back like I can be determined
focused enough and diligence enough and
dedicated enough to leverage those
moments when I make that decision to
really make significant changes that
that's stick and stand the test of time
I mean for me I try to keep it as simple
as possible it's about making a decision
when I make a decision that decision is
done I've done it with diet I've done it
with Fitness I've done it with my
profession and the more simple I can
make it then the easier it is to adhere
you know we're so conditioned tom to
avoid pain every message that we see
every billboard we see every
advertisement that we're exposed to is
telling us that happiness can be can be
purchased through comfort through luxury
through ease and that's sort of implicit
in that is that that's how we find
happiness and I can tell you that I'm
happiest and most alive when I'm butting
up against the outer edges of my pain
threshold and I'm not afraid of it and
so when I start to feel that sensation
rather than shirk away from it I realize
that's an opportunity to experience a
heightened sense of myself and my
environment to to really be in a
position where everything else falls
away and it's just you and your ability
to take one step forward there's a
purity to that that again is another
great teacher and so in terms of
techniques I've just learned through
experience that just like David Goggin
says when the signals that you're
receiving are telling you to stop that
you don't necessarily have to pay
attention to that that that you are
capable of so much more if you can
develop the acuity the presence of mind
and the wherewithal to then take that
next step and when you're on the other
side of it to realize you're still okay
and you can take another step and a
whole your horizon extends and you
realize that there's a whole world of
potential and possibility available to
you that you weren't previously aware of
no it definitely didn't have a corporate
lawyer for many years I was the
corporate lawyer
during a period of time that I wrote
that book and the book was successful
and yet in the wake of that book being
published and doing well the phone
didn't ring and I had let my bar bar
membership lapse and here I was you know
ready and available to speak to the
world and and be of service and the
opportunities just weren't flowing it
was a very difficult time and it it
tested me to my core I mean we almost
lost our house I had cars repossessed we
could their bills it was very
emasculating but I think the the alchemy
of going through that has been something
that now allows me to speak from a place
of greater truth and
so I'm grateful for the experience the
part that really hit me was when you
said that you guys can't even pay for
your trash taken away and they could
that's when I realized okay wait this
wasn't like Oh things were tight this
was like we can't pay $60 for our
garbage to be picked up it was the worst
he's so embarrassing mosz so incredibly
emasculating yeah we went through
periods where we literally barely had
enough money to put food on the table
and we couldn't take a harsh we couldn't
pay to have our our trash removed and
they did they came and they took the
bins and then we were compelled to then
put our trash in the back of our crappy
beat-up minivan and find an empty
dumpster to do to dump the to dump the
garbage it was it was not easy so I for
kids and it's something that was very
challenging as a parent and again I keep
using the word emasculating as somebody
who who you know is supposed to be the
head of household and and take care of
these sorts of things to be unable to do
that was incredibly difficult I worked
my ass off and exploited every
opportunity that presented itself I did
a ton of speaking gigs for free I did
anything that was asked of me anyone who
would want to talk to me but it was
really just a function of showing up
working my ass off saying yes and having
a strong core belief that I was on the
right path I was somebody who who for as
long as I could remember was pursuing
the traditional notion of the American
Dream get into the best college study
hard get into the best grad school get
the best job show up early stay late
partnership track all of that right but
that I'd never really stopped to think
what is important to me like Who am I am
like what am I here to express and they
didn't have answers for those questions
all I knew was that I felt like I was
living someone else's life
and so my exploration
in sobriety and ultimately then in ultra
endurance sports was really my personal
method of trying to resolve these issues
for myself to try to learn Who I am you
know one thing you talk about all the
time is goals setting goals and being
very clear about what those goals are I
think that that most people set the
wrong goals for themselves and it's
because they're disconnected from who
they are they are living someone else's
life or they're living a life that's so
disconnected from who they are it
becomes very difficult to set the right
goal so I think in order to reconcile
that you have to look inward you know
and that can be different for everybody
that can mean a consistent meditation
practice that can mean therapy that can
mean you know starting to do yoga
it can mean many many things but I think
there's no end run around the very
difficult long process of really trying
to be honest with yourself about who you
are what's important to you what you
care about and then beginning to breathe
life into those things as frivolous as
they may seem to bring expression to the
things that that you do care about that
that that get you excited in the morning
and that doesn't mean you quit your job
tomorrow but the more you can foster
something that has personal importance
to you I think that's the first step in
trying to move past whatever it is
that's holding you back
whether it's professionally or
personally to being a more integrated
authentic version of yourself we're all
spiritual beings having a human
experience and I don't mean that in any
specific dogmatic sense certainly not in
any specific religious sense but I do
what I do mean by that is that there's
more to this experience of being human
than meets the eye there's more to it
than we can possibly comprehend
and I think there are energies available
to us if we open our perspective and
become more curious about the world then
I think we're programmed to be so for me
that doesn't I don't define that by any
particular specific spiritual approach
other than that it provides my
experience as a human being with a
little bit more awe and wonder than I
used to have you know as somebody who as
I explained earlier as a young person I
did the math and I realized if I outwork
everybody in the pool
I can be as good as anyone else if I
outwork everyone in the classroom I can
graduate at the top of my class and get
into Stanford and Harvard and so my
worldview was informed through the prism
of those experiences which taught me
self-reliance is everything don't don't
expect anybody to do anything for you
I'm the only one who can get it done and
if you just buckle down and go the extra
mile you will solve the problem and you
will make your way in the world every
success that I had had in my life was a
result of myself well why won't my self
well solve this problem and that hole
got deeper and deeper and deeper until I
was a completely broken human being and
I had to raise my hand and ask for help
for the first time and that forced me to
start to think about letting go and
surrender in a new way and I've come to
believe and understand that surrender is
a very powerful courageous thing to do
it's okay to say you don't know it's
okay to ask for help I had to let go of
this operating system and step into a
sense that perhaps there's a better way
a greater way that involves me saying I
can't control this which was terrifying
for me
but it is in that process that I allowed
people to help me that I became open to
a new way of approaching my life that
has made me stronger more powerful more
capable and more successful than I ever
thought that I ever would be it goes
back to what I was saying before about
people picking the wrong goals for
themselves because they're not
integrated they don't know what their
values are they're not clear on what's
important to them they're not really in
contact with their internal muse you
know one of the examples I always give
is this idea that we all have some
unique song here to sing on planet earth
like I believe that and that doesn't
mean that everybody can be liberal and
James or that you have some insane
talent but I believe that there is a
unique blueprint to every individual and
our job here you know in our short time
on this planet is to discover what that
is and to work towards expressing that
to the best of your ability you know we
all have a unique song and I think most
people to echo the words of Henry David
Thoreau are leading lives of quiet
desperation and go to the grave with the
song still in them and I find that
tragic and so if there's anything that
that that my work is about it's about
helping people become cognizant of that
and to take action so that they don't
become that person leading a life of
quiet desperation which I think I don't
know I wouldn't want to say most people
but a lot of people are and and I found
out heartbreaking if you're if you're
eating garbage food if you're eating
fast food and you're not sleeping and
you're you know drinking five cups of
coffee a day or whatever it is you're
doing and you're stressed out about your
job and you're just living moment to
moment to get through the day do you
think that you're gonna be in touch with
whatever is really important to you
you're just trying to like you know hit
the pillow at night and pay the bills
and that's most people and if you give
people a minute to pause and reflect and
you can clear all of that out and feed
them healthy food and
a good night's rest and ask them
questions that most people aren't asking
them and they're certainly not asking
them themselves I think that's the
process that begins our sets in motion
the the gears in the mind and in the
emotional body to begin to bring all of
that to the surface you know what's your
major malfunction right now what's the
thing that keeps you up at night who do
you resent the most what are you afraid
of what do you want to achieve what's in
what's in what do you think is in your
way you know I think just by asking
people questions and and and and then
holding a vision for that better life
for them to say I believe in you
I'm not here to tell you what to do or
how to live your life but I believe in
your greatest expression and I'm going
to hold space for you to give people
permission to be honest to be vulnerable
we're so afraid of being vulnerable
we're terrified of being honest we're so
used to being judged and being held to a
standard that society sets for us that
we don't give ourselves permission to
even ask these questions let alone
answer them I would like to move the
needle in a substantial and long-lasting
way for as many people as possible with
respect to not only how they think about
and practice habits around food and
fitness and lifestyle but to really
catalyze people to understand that like
I said earlier all of us every single
one of us is capable of so much more
than we allow ourselves to believe and I
know that's a theme on your show David
Goggins talked about it James Lawrence
talked about it these are friends of
mine who have touched the outer realms
of endurance and ultra endurance teaches
you that it's easy to say I'm an outlier
but I'm not I really am NOT anything
special I had the courage and the
audacity to pursue these things and in
so doing I have realized that human
potential is malleable we're all sitting
in top massive reservoirs of untapped
potential and ability and my dream and
my goal and everything that I do is
oriented around getting people to not
only understand that but connect with
that and begin to practice that to
manifest that in their own specific way